the more information that comes out
about the texas elementary school
shooting the worse the story gets
i had generally refrained on this show
from commenting on the reports that
uvalde cops waited outside and even
prevented other people from going in
while the shooter was inside wreaking
havoc
i wanted to wait until more information
came out and was confirmed now that
information seems to have been confirmed
by the texas department of public safety
hey from the for the benefit of
hindsight where i'm sitting now
then of course it was not the right
decision it was a wrong decision period
there's no no excuse for that
but again i wasn't there but i'm just
telling you from what we know
we believe there should have been an
entry at that as soon as you can hey
when there's an active shooter the rules
change it's no longer okay
it's no longer a barricade itself you
don't have time you don't worry about
matter primers and by the way texas
embraces active shooter training active
shooter certification and that that dot
that doctrine
requires officers we don't care what
agency you're from you don't have to
have a leader on the scene every officer
lines up stacks up goes and finds where
those rounds are being fired at and
keeps shooting until the subject is dead
period
there you have it of course it was the
wrong decision people are calling the
response
at uvalde
incompetent cowardly unconscionable
people want heads to roll people want
the department defunded in some cases
they want whoever gave the stand down
order to get dragged before a judge and
put on an orange jumpsuit
i get it
but that does not concern me
that is not my call or your call for
that matter that is for the people of
uvalde to decide what does concern us
what concerns all of us
is the central lesson of this horrible
ordeal
namely that we cannot rely on the cops
to protect us
we cannot rely on the politicians to
protect us
we have a right and an obligation to
protect ourselves and our children
and as cynical political activists try
to exploit this tragedy to push their
long-standing political agenda
more than ever we need to defend those
rights
i do not understand how you can possibly
hear
about the police response to the uvalde
shooting
and defend weakening the second
amendment i know
that this has been the political
response certainly from the left and
among some squishes too is to say well
because of this horrific shooting and
the extremely botched response to it we
need to give up our guns that seems like
the opposite of what you would conclude
if you
the reason to give up your guns the
reason to surrender the second amendment
is well
the cops will take care of it you don't
need to be armed because we pay our
taxes and the state provides us people
who are going to protect us if we're
ever in jeopardy if we're ever in in any
risk
but they won't in some cases they will
in some cases they won't you can't rely
on that
that's the point
ironically this this whole botched
response is proving
what what many of us already knew namely
you have a right and an obligation that
is totally natural to self-defense
you see
you see this from the shooting up in
buffalo do you remember the shooting in
buffalo not that long ago just a few
weeks ago
this lunatic who was says he was
radicalized on the internet during covet
and his political views were a little
bit unclear he said he was on the
authoritarian left but he's he said he
had moved further right and he used to
be a communist and then he was kind of
right-wing and then he was left-wing
again and was all it was all
part of this ideological transformation
on the internet
now there are news reports
that this guy
may have had contact with a retired
federal agent
on the internet
how long was that contact
what did that contact with the federal
agent have to do with his radicalization
what did that federal agent know and
when did he know it there were reports
coming out
that this federal agent had advanced
notice of the shooting authorities are
investigating whether or not
he had a warning and who knows how long
that war maybe it was half an hour it
might have been longer than that
this is raising a lot of questions
what was the role of that federal agent
people have raised questions before
about the fed's role in some of these
attacks you remember the the plot to
kidnap gretchen whitmer in michigan we
were told that this was a radical white
supremacist far-right group that was
plotting to kidnap the democrat governor
of michigan then we found out
actually federal agents were involved in
that actually federal agents were
entrapping people in that
and some of the guys got off the hook
because of it
so so the question is what was the i'm
not saying that the retired federal
agent here
was
enticing this guy to commit the shooting
or was entrapping him or doing anything
like that i guess it's possible there
will be an investigation here
but but there are three options as to
what this federal agent was doing
the federal agent was either
encouraging him
entrapping him inciting him
or the federal agent was
trying to do something like that and was
just completely incompetent
or the federal agent was a neo-nazi and
actually agreed with the guy
those are the only three options as far
as i can tell
what else could this guy have been doing
interacting with this killer why else
would this guy have gotten advanced
notice about the shooting if he was not
involved in some way if there were not
some operation going on here
to to investigate and entrap white
supremacists or
the the agent just had no idea what he
was doing or
the agent was on the guy's team
in any of those cases
you need to protect yourself
none of those possible scenarios look
very good for the federal agent or for
law enforcement
if these reports are true we don't know
if they're true yet there will be an
investigation
all that does is add more
evidence
to the to the argument that you need to
be able to protect yourself
all around you've got law and order
crumbling in the country and the justice
system isn't doing anything about it
there was a video went viral over the
weekend of thieves in los angeles they
break into sephora the makeup store and
these guys just by the looks of them
it's hard to tell because they're
wearing hoodies and they're trying to
cover up their identities but just by
the looks of them i don't think that
they're
all that interested in putting makeup on
themselves they have big black trash
bags and they're just emptying out store
shelves with no consequences
this is about three of these guys
and they're just being filmed too i love
these bystanders they're not stopping
them there's no guard coming out and
stopping them they're just filming i
guess it's good that they're filming we
can at least
at least
see what's going on
and these dudes have no fear in the
world no one's going to come stop them
see you
there you go all right they got it just
walking right out
they're not even they're not even
running they're walking out that's how
little fear they have of law enforcement
and it's not even the cops fault in los
angeles in los angeles it's because the
george soros-backed district attorney
has said that he's not going to
prosecute these guys
so there's no surprise there if you've
got a radical leftist d.a
encouraging this kind of crime then
that's the kind of crime you're going to
get
and even if the cops wanted to do
something they wouldn't be able to
because the political superiors won't
let them if you are in los angeles if
like i was i lived in los angeles a long
time i would not feel safe relying on
the cops to protect me and my family and
my rights and my property or anything
else
and what's tough in los angeles is it's
very hard to get a concealed carry
permit it's basically impossible to get
a concealed carry permit
so what would you do
well you could either move out to one of
the counties around it where it's easier
to get a gun and protect yourself or you
move out of the state entirely which is
what we did it's not just los angeles
look at what's going on in new york in
new york
subway attacks have always occurred they
are becoming more commonplace and they
are becoming more brazen
this crazy guy
running around yelling i think it's a
guy
he's dressed up in women's clothing but
he looks like a guy
sits down next to these women they start
to get up and oh
there he goes this this woman sitting
next to him tries to get he grabs her by
the back of the hair
pulls her back down she looks terrified
as of course she should be
she's saying help me she's kind of
mouthing this to other people she's
remaining pretty calm though
and no one's doing a damn thing no one's
lifting a finger
guys just sitting there holding her down
there's someone filming her
how about the guy filming her puts the
camera down and goes and helps her
nope not doing that not in social media
age finally the guy gets up
yells at the woman get up
and lets her go
i think he's wearing women's clothing
yeah it's definitely dude though wearing
women's clothing and women's pants
what has happened in this country where
everyone on that subway is just going to
sit by and let bad people do whatever
they want to helpless women who are
saying please help me help me nobody
does anything because we are in a a
state right now in this country where no
one feels the
the urgency or the ability to protect
ourselves we're all going to let
somebody else handle it for us i got
news for you folks the the cavalry's not
coming in okay you can't rely on other
people to protect yourself you've got to
begin to to re-learn how to do it
yourself i'm glad you like that clip now
you got a ring
ding subscribe smash like whatever you
got to do get the notifications for the
michael knowles show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you